Und ich habe diesen Knopfgewehr, der verantwortlich Terrorist, geworfen. Auf Wiedersehen!
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 37. Und das Thema heute führt uns in die Lüfte. Es geht um das Luftsicherheitsgesetz und seine Auswirkungen und insbesondere seine Motivationen. Zu Gast bei Chaosradio Express dazu, Björn Rupp und am Mikrofon führt durch die Sendung, wie gewohnt, Tim Pritlove. Ja, willkommen zurück bei Chaosradio Express. Ja, ich begrüße erstmal hier meinen Gast. Hallo Björn. Ja, Björn, du bist so einiges, aber du bist vor allem auch seit einiger Zeit Pilot geworden, hast einen Flugschein gemacht und seitdem kurzt du so ein bisschen durch die Lüfte. Das ist ja nun nicht so eine alltägliche Tätigkeit, auch wenn es sicherlich einige Piloten gibt auf diesem Planeten. Wann hast du einen Pilotenschein gemacht?
Das war, wenn ich mich nicht irre, 2002.
2002. Und was ist das so für eine Prozedur, die man dadurch schreiten muss, um heutzutage ein Flugzeug zu führen?
Nein, du hast ja am Anfang schon gesagt, das wäre eigentlich gar nicht so was Normales. Dabei ist es eigentlich, wenn man sich überlegt, eigentlich doch was ganz Normales, nur dass es eine dritte Dimension dazu gibt. Und klar, es ist ein bisschen mehr als der übliche Führerschein und ein bisschen mehr als Mopedfahren ist es schon. Aber im Prinzip ist das Prozedere genauso, wie wenn man jetzt einen Führerschein haben wollte. Man geht halt zu einer Flugschule statt zu einer Fahrschule. Und wie in der Fahrschule auch, lernt man erst mal die Theorie. Dann setzt man sich ins Auto, schön mit einem Lehrer rechts. In dem Fall gibt es noch ein zweites Steuer, was das Ganze noch ein bisschen komfortabler macht. Und wenn man dann alles durch hat, also erst die Theorie und dann die Praxis, dann kann man halt mit seinem Flugzeug bzw. mit dem gemieteten Flugzeug, genauso wie mit dem Auto, sonst auch ganz normal, und das Normal ist wirklich das Entscheidende hier, von A nach B fliegen.
Und gibt es dann auch so diese Multiple-Choice-Bögen, die man ausfüllen muss? Man muss eigentlich nur die Geometrie des Standard-Layouts kennen, um die richtigen Antworten zu machen?
Da sind es ein bisschen zu viele Fragen. Vor allem ist es vom Stoff her doch schon relativ viel. Und es sind alle sehr disjunkte Wissensgebiete. Aerodynamik, Meteorologie, Recht und so weiter und so fort. Das hat alles relativ wenig miteinander zu tun. Und es sind glaube ich ein bisschen zu viele Fragen, um sich die Geometrie ausfindig zu lernen. Aber sonst, also, es gibt keinen Grund, warum das ein eleganter Mensch nicht machen könnte.
Okay, aber man wird auf jeden Fall doch recht umfangreich geprüft und schon ein bisschen härter ran genommen, als es jetzt für das Führen eines normalen Fahrzeugs im Straßenverkehr nötig wäre.
Da schon, es gibt ja auch noch das Medical, also es hat die medizinische Tauglichkeit, die muss halt auch regelmäßig nachgewiesen sind. Nicht, dass man da mit dem Herz klappt, irgendwie dummerweise zum falschen Zeitpunkt am falschen Ort, nämlich deutlich über dem nächsten Krankenhaus kommt. Und dann geht es dann erst mal abwärts.
Wie oft muss man das machen?
Das hängt davon ab, ob man jetzt Berufspilot ist oder Privatpilot. Berufspiloten müssen das jedes Jahr machen. Privatpiloten alle zwei Jahre. Das gibt es wieder auch verschiedene Unterprüfungen, die dann in verschiedenen Abständen gemacht werden müssen, je nachdem. Also manche Sachen halten wesentlich größeren Abständen, einige häufiger und so weiter und so fort. Aber so im groben Rahmen kann man sagen, als Privatpilot alle zwei Jahre.
Okay, jetzt hast du einen Pilotenschein. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt jederzeit zum Flugplatz laden und sagen, ich möchte hier einmal in die Lüfte steigen.
Ja, genauso ist das.
Und dann geht man dahin und mietet sich irgendwie ein Flugzeug. Und dann steigt man ein und fliegt los.
Genauso. Das ist nämlich eigentlich das, also alle denken immer, es gibt dann so Fragen wie, ja, darfst du damit auch ins Ausland fliegen? Und dann darfst du jedes und solches. Da fragen wir, ja, warum soll ich das denn nicht? Also es würde ja auch keiner auf die Idee kommen, irgendwie jemand, wenn er in sein Auto steigt, zu fragen, ich würde sagen mal, also nach Holland, darfst du damit etwa auch?
Na ja gut, beim Mietwagen so, nach Polen. Also so einfach finde ich ist das nicht unbedingt immer.
Ja, das mit die Stahlgefahr, die ist halt echt niedriger, das muss man mal so sagen. Das ist echt gut. Man kann auch, wenn man sich die Schlösser an diesen Flugzeugen so anguckt, das ist ja, also jeder Lockpicker würde da einmal herzlich drüber lachen. Aber mit dem Diebstahl, das ist ja echt, die Gefahr ist eigentlich eher nicht da. Also so ein Flugzeug ist dann doch eine Sache, die taucht nicht plötzlich irgendwo im Hinterhof wieder auf.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Und sonst, wie gesagt, man kann einfach, also man kann ein Flugzeug mieten, wenn man kein eigenes hat.
Aber es werden da sicherlich auch Flugzeuge geklaut, oder?
Weil wie gesagt, die kann man schlecht im Hinterhaufen abstellen.
Gut, und wie groß muss man sich das Fliegerphänomen vorstellen? Also wie viele Piloten hast du da irgendwie eine Ahnung? Wie viele ausgebildete oder vielleicht auch aktiv fliegende Piloten gibt es so in Deutschland?
Die Zahl wusste ich mal jetzt nicht mehr. Es sind eine ganze Menge, vor allem 95 Prozent davon sind Privatpiloten, die nach Sichtflugregeln unterwegs sind. Also das reicht halt vom Motorseglerpiloten bis zum Geschäftsflieger. Und es ist auch kaum einem bewusst, wie viele Flugplätze es in Deutschland gibt. Es ist eigentlich irre, gerade für diejenigen, die nur die großen Verkehrsflughäfen kennen. Es gibt eigentlich in Deutschland so fast alle 50 Kilometer irgendwo einen kleinen Platz. Das ist jetzt dann halt nix mit Terminal und großer Betonrollbahn, sondern einfach eine wiese mit einer schönen Graspiste und ein paar Flugzeuge daneben. Aber man kann wirklich in Deutschland, auch in Westeuropa, wirklich sehr einfach, sehr schnell, sehr bequem von einem Punkt zum anderen kommen, ohne dass man dadurch mit sich mit irgendwelchen Staus oder ähnlichen Unheimlichkeiten lebt.
Ja, das mit den Flugplätzen ist mir vor kurzem auch nochmal bewusst geworden, als ich den passenden Layer aktiviert habe in Google Earth, wo ja insbesondere für Flieger doch eine ganze Menge Ressourcen drin sind. Also Flugplätze sind sowieso bevorzugt erfasst bei Google Earth. Also auch in sehr schlecht kartografierten Gebieten sind die Flugplätze meistens dann nochmal mit einem Extra-Patch ausgestattet, damit man das da schon früh sehen kann. Da wird einem das schon so ein bisschen bewusst. Aber um das nochmal klar zu machen, es gibt so ein internationales Abkommen. Wie hieß noch gleich diese Organisation, die das macht?
Die International Civil Aviation Organisation.
Und die regelt das so ein bisschen wie?
Das ist so wie die ITU der Luftphase, kann man sich das vorstellen. Also es ist jetzt keine Organisation, die losgelöst von allem anderen entstehen würde, sondern die ist 1948, wenn ich mich irre, durch Beschluss der Mitgliedstaaten aus der Taufe gehoben worden. Da eiligen wir uns ja auf gemeinsame Regeln und das hat halt einfach große Vorteile, weil im Wesentlichen eigentlich alles weltweit vereinheitlich ist. Also klar, jeder Staat kann seinen eigenen Luftraum so einrichten, wer das gerade viel zweckmäßig hält, ist auch richtig so. Aber halt so gewisse Regeln, so salopp gesprochen, rechts vor links und so weiter, gilt halt weltweit. Und dadurch kann man auch problemlos wirklich von einem Land ins andere fliegen. Es gibt auch detaillierte Regeln, dass die Mitgliedstaaten auch sich gegenseitig da Überflug- und Einflugrechte einräumen und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, das ist ja alles ganz romantisch. Und wie heißt es da so schön? Über den Wolken muss die Freiheit wohl grenzenlos sein. Aber da kommen wir jetzt nämlich so langsam mal zum Kernthema dieser Sendung. Da ändert sich es gerade doch massiv. 2004 wurde ein neues Gesetz beschlossen, das sogenannte Luftsicherheitsgesetz. Aus welcher Motivation heraus ist das entstanden? Und was betrifft dieses Luftsicherheitsgesetz im Wesentlichen? Es gab ja sämtlich schon vorher ein Luftsicherheitsgesetz. Ist das eine Verschärfung des Luftsicherheitsgesetzes oder ist das jetzt überhaupt das erste Luftsicherheitsgesetz, was es in dem Sinne gab?
Also Regeln gibt es natürlich für alles und für jedes in Deutschland schon seit mehr oder weniger immer. Aber dieses Luftsicherheitsgesetz als solches ist durchaus komplett neu. Und bei allem, was das Wort Sicherheit irgendwo im Namen hat, kann man sich schon denken, wo die Motivation herkommt und wie viele Jahre das jetzt her ist, dass diese Motivation da langsam entstand. Und so war es auch in diesem Fall. Das Luftsicherheitsgesetz entstand so aus dem Bedürfnis, dem Bürger zu erläutern, dass man doch ganz viel tut, um die Sicherheit im Luftverkehr zu erhöhen. Da gab es bis vor einiger Zeit auch noch diesen großartigen Paragraph 14, Absatz 3. Der sah bei vorliegenden bestimmten Umständen auch den gezielten Abschluss von Verkehrsflugzeugen durch Entscheid des Verteidigungsministers vor. Das ist ja prima. Wenn das eine Gefahr ist, dann machen wir da einfach mal. Ja, genau. Erstens fällt das ja nirgends wohin. Das löst sich dann einfach in Luft aus. Und zweitens, die Leute, die dann da an Bord sind, das sind ja eigentlich...
Das ist ja belegt. Das haben wir im Pentagon ja gesehen. Flugzeuge, die irgendwo auftreffen, verbrennen vollständig rückstandsfrei. Also da kann eigentlich relativ wenig passieren. Das Ganze war ja, wenn ich mich nicht richtig erinnere, die ganze Hektik brach aus, als da irgend so ein verspulter über Frankfurt, glaube ich, mit seinem kleinen Flugzeug durch die Gegend geflogen ist. Da brach dann so dieser Aktionismus aus.
Das war auch so eine ganz besonders spaßige Geschichte. Da war ein verwirrter Motorsieglerpilot, der irgendwie Liebeskummer hatte. Der hat einen Motorsiegler geklaut, nicht entführt, wie es manchmal heißt. Der hat einfach geklaut. Da ist mal einer der wenigen Fälle, wo dann noch mal das Flugzeug geklaut wurde. Ja, und ist dann über Frankfurt rumgeflogen, war ein bisschen einsam, hat alle in große Aufregung versetzt. Dann hat die Luftwaffe sogar noch mal zwei Phantomjets dahingeschickt. Man hätte sich fragen können, was denn bei Bordwaffeneinsatz wirklich passiert wäre. Also was da den größeren Schaden anrichten würde, denn so ein Motorsegler, wenn der gegen einen Hochraus fliegt, der Motorsegler ist dann kaputt. Das Hochraus eher nicht.
Ja, aber das war doch dieser Auslöser in der Öffentlichkeit. Ich kann mich da noch ein bisschen daran erinnern, zumindest kam es dann vermehrt durch die Medien und dann hatten es auf einmal wieder alle ganz einig. Dieses Luftsicherheitsgesetz umfasst aber jetzt doch noch eine ganze Menge mehr Punkte. Ich weiß nicht, gibt es da auch ein paar sinnvolle Paragrafen in diesem Luftsicherheitsgesetz oder ist das eigentlich komplett pointless?
Also mir ist noch nicht so aufgefallen, was ich jetzt als unbedingt sinnvoll und zweckhaft empfunden hätte.
Aber dir ist auf jeden Fall etwas aufgefallen, was dir absolut nicht sinnvoll, was du als nicht sinnvoll erachtest. Du hast darüber ja auch ein Artikel geschrieben in der letzten Datenschleuder und Kern der Beklagung ist die sogenannte Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung, die dort durch dieses Gesetz vorgesehen wird. Worum handelt es sich dabei?
Ja, das ist ja etwas, was jetzt nicht nur mir aufgefallen ist, sondern also dieses ganze Gesetz ist ja in seiner Erlesen handwerklichen Qualität schon diversen Leuten aufgefallen, nicht zuletzt auch dem Verfassungsgericht. Wie gesagt, dieser Abschlussparagraf ist ja mittlerweile gestrichen gekippt. Aber da gibt es noch eine ganze Menge andere Sachen, wie zum Beispiel halt diese Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung. Das ist geregelt in § 7 dieses Gesetzes. Und das hat im Wesentlichen den Inhalt, dass Piloten ja schon mal per se in Gefahr sind. Und deswegen müssen die alle mal überprüft werden, dass die auch wirklich zuverlässig sind. Das heißt, jeder fliegende Bürger wird einmal durchschnittlich von, ich glaube, so ziemlich allen Behörden, die in diesem Staat so potentiell dafür infrage kommen könnten, einmal durchleuchtet. Und das Ganze wird dann in eine Akte zusammengetragen und auf Basis dieser Akte wird dann entschieden, ob man zuverlässig ist oder nicht. Und wenn nicht, dann ist man halt auch leider seine Lizenz los.
Ja, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die Behörden einen überprüfen, sondern es ist ja andersrum. Es ist ja so, dass man nicht nachgewiesen bekommt, dass man unbedenklich ist, sondern es ist ja so, dass man selber losziehen muss und Belege dafür erbringen muss, dass man selber unbedenklich ist.
Ja, das ist schon ganz lustig, weil ja doch zumindest derzeit noch die geltenden Gesetze in diesem Lande es nicht zulassen, dass der Staat jetzt mal in dieser Allgemeinheit gesprochen loszieht und Daten munte übereinsammelt. Also alles, was das verfügbar ist, also Polizei, Strafvollzugsbehörden, Verfassungsschutz, MIT, Stasi und so weiter und so fort. Dass alles in einer Akte zusammenschaufelt und dann sagt, ja prima, das ist ja sowieso unser gutes Recht. Das haben wir auch sowieso schon alles immer so gesammelt, wie jeder weiß. Insofern entscheiden wir jetzt mal anhand dessen. Nein, nein, das ist viel raffinierter, weil der Staat das ja nicht darf. Wird also in diesem Paragrafen 7 geregelt, dass doch bitte der fliegende Bürger selber diesen Antrag stellt. Das hat natürlich ein paar ganz pikante Feinheiten. Ich stelle also freiwillig in Anführungsstrichen einen Antrag darauf, dass man mich doch bitte überprüfen und meine Zuverlässigkeit feststellen möge, und erkläre dann im Kleingedruckten halt noch, dass Unterlagen zugezogen dürfen von Polizeivorzugs- und Verfassungsschutzbehörden der Länder, dann Bundes- und Zahlkriminalamt, Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, Bundesnachrichtendienst, medizinische Abschirmdienst und natürlich hier die Bundesbeauftragung für Unterlagen der Staatssicherheit und so weiter.
Das heißt, man unterschreibt sozusagen den Verzicht auf seine Grundrechte, dass genau diese Daten nicht zentral eingezogen werden dürfen, ohne dass jetzt ein Verdacht vorliegt oder wie muss man das verstehen?
Ja, so steht das natürlich noch nicht drin, aber in dem Antrag sagt man halt, also sammelt mal schön und stellt das mal fest. Ich stelle ja selber den Antrag dazu, also ist das Tolle. Da tut ja niemand was von sich selbst aus, sondern ich habe ja selber darum gebeten und dadurch setze ich sozusagen auch das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz für mich selber erst mal außer Kraft. Könnte man jetzt gehässig unterstellen. Und ja, dann sammelt mal schön, ich habe euch ja sozusagen den Auftrag gegeben. Ich kann natürlich auch, das ist ja das Tolle, ich kann natürlich auch diesen Antrag verweigern, den einfach nicht stellen. Leider, wie dann auch in der nächsten Fußnude steht, hat das aber auch zwingend zur Folge, dass man dann leider auch nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass ich zuverlässig bin und das wiederum heißt natürlich, dass man leider auch mir die Lizenz entziehen muss. Ja, also ist eine ganz freiwillige Geschichte jedenfalls.
Und wie häufig muss diese Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung durchgeführt werden oder wie häufig muss man einen Antrag stellen?
Ja, da geht es erstmal um den Initialen Antrag, den haben wir jetzt alle mal durch. Wie gesagt, das Gesetz wurde ja 2004 beschlossen, trat Anfang 2005 in Kraft. Und dann sieht das Gesetz eigentlich vor, dass man das jedes Jahr neu stellt.
Das heißt, du hast das jetzt einmal getan, du hast einmal diesen Antrag gestellt und hast gesagt, hier, ich verzichte jetzt erstmal auf meine Datenschutzrechte im Kern.
Ja, das mussten ja alle tun. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, als ob da...
Ja, ja, schon klar. Du hast das jetzt auch getan und was musstest du dann noch mitliefern in diesem Antrag, also welcherlei Dokumente? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt nicht explizit gefragt wird nach bestimmten Sachen, was muss man denn dann präsentieren oder geht es nur darum, dass man einmal unterschreibt, okay, ab jetzt dürft ihr mich komplett ausspionieren, dann ziehen die los, legen eine dicke Fette Akte überein an und dann schauen sie sich das an und gucken, ob das korrekt ist. Muss man sich das so vorstellen?
Ja, so ungefähr, ein bisschen spezifischer sollte man schon noch sein, weil man ja auch den Leuten die Arbeit erleichtern will. Man ist ja auch nach dem Gesetz zur Mitwirkung bei der eigenen Durchforschung verpflichtet. Ach, insofern geht es da erstmal alle Geburtsoorte, quatsch, alle Wohnorte seit der Geburt aufzuführen. Das sind ja doch, wenn man mal ein bisschen mobil unterwegs ist, doch da läppert sicher was zusammen. Und ja, dann werden halt alle, die in diesen verschiedenen Orten da möglicherweise was beizutragen können, mal befragt. Wer also auch befragt werden darf, sind zum Beispiel der derzeitige Arbeitgeber, dann die Flugplatzunternehmen und das weiß ich nicht alles.
Also überall, wo man mal gestartet ist oder was?
Ja, und also auch bei dem, bei dem man vielleicht mal mietet oder der Arbeitgeber oder auch, das ist halt auch die Frage, wenn man jetzt in der ehemaligen DDR groß geworden ist und dann kommen diese Stasi-Unterlagen da natürlich, wer weiß, ob da der Nachbar nicht mal was Böses über einen gesagt hat, ja, das kann sich als alles potenziell auch negativ auswirken.
Aber das sind ja keine festgestellten Straftaten in dem Sinne.
Nö, aber das ist ja auch das Schöne daran, es gibt ja auch hier, bei dieser Zuflässigüberprüfung, keine klaren Kriterien, also das sollte man eigentlich denken, dass es sowas geben sollte, es ist ja doch eine entscheidende, also für das berufliche oder private Leben des einen sind durchaus eine massive Einschränkung, die da möglicherweise auf einen zukommt, da würde man ja denken, naja gut, also das ist jetzt zwar alles eine harte Sache, aber das wird sicherlich ganz streng geregelt sein, welche Kriterien da einen als zuverlässig oder nicht zuverlässig erscheinen lassen, dem ist aber nicht so, also es heißt zwar in dem Gesetz auch, dass die Einzelheiten durch Rechtsverordnungen zu regeln seien, diese Durchführungsverordnung ist aber bis heute nicht erschienen, das heißt, der Befund darüber, ob man jetzt zuverlässig ist oder nicht, liegt letztendlich im Ermessen des Angenommen. Der oder die Beamte kommt halt aufgrund von begründeten oder nicht begründeten Gründen, wie auch immer, kommt halt zum Entschluss. Person X ist halt nicht zuverlässig, sollte sich nicht in der Luft über Deutschland aufhalten. Dann würde man jetzt da eigentlich sagen, bei so einem Verfahren, okay, möglicherweise ist dann ja der Betroffene anderer Meinung und kann dann dagegen Rechtsmittel einlegen. Das ist in diesem Fall aber natürlich nicht so, weil die Erkenntnisse sind ja im Zweifelsfall geheim und Geheimerkennnisse kann man natürlich nicht mitteilen. Insofern gibt es da leider auch keine Möglichkeit, sozusagen Berufung einzulegen.
Ach, das heißt, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, erstmal, man hat einen Pilotenschein, hat im Prinzip alle voraussetzungen, alle technischen Voraussetzungen erfüllt und gegebenenfalls auch alle medizinischen Voraussetzungen erfüllt. Man weiß, wie man fliegt und man weiß, wie man startet und landet. Man kennt alle Regeln. So, dann möchte man irgendwie fliegen, aber dann sagen die, na ja, aber sind sie denn auch unbedenklich? Dann fragt man in sich im Prinzip, ja, was heißt denn das? Und dann sagen sie, na, das können wir ihnen so genau nicht sagen, aber überprüfen müssen wir es trotzdem.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Und dann ist man selber gezwungen, Auskunft zu geben in dem Staat, sozusagen alle Nachforschung, die normalerweise explizit verboten sind, zu erlauben, um am Ende zu einem Beschluss zu kommen, der einem noch nicht mal mitgeteilt werden darf?
Ja, der Beschluss darf einem ja schon mitgeteilt werden, nur die Gründe darf nicht, ne? Also ich meine, es gab ja auch schon vorher durchaus Kriterien, die über jetzt die reine Technik komplett hinaus, was weiß ich. Die sind auch alle wirklich sehr sinnvoll. Also jetzt wirklich, was weiß ich, wer jetzt betrunken Auto fährt und regelmäßig Verkehrsstraftaten verübt, der hat natürlich auch im Flugzeug nichts zu suchen, das ist auch total sinnvoll. Aber da war halt auch mal klar geregelt, okay, dass und das geht, dass und das geht nicht. Also jetzt hier mit 200.000 Punkten in Flensburg ist leider Schluss. Nur jetzt mit dieser Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung ist halt, wie gesagt, weh dem, der mal Ärger mit den falschen Leuten gehabt hat.
Und wie häufig muss jetzt diese Überprüfung gemacht werden? Also wenn man jetzt einmal unbedenklich ist, ist man dann für immer unbedenklich?
Nee, wie gesagt, das muss jedes Jahr wiederholt werden. Es gab da jetzt zwar schon die ersten Rückzieher, nachdem was so zu verlautbaren war.
Da müsste es ja jetzt im Prinzip schon ein zweites Mal dran gewesen sein.
Korrekt, ja. Der Antrag ist mir auch wieder zurückgeschickt worden. Mit dem Hinweis darauf, dass man jetzt doch noch auf die Durchführungsverordnung wartet.
Es gab, es gibt aber auch schon gerichtliche Klagen oder sogar eine Verfassungsbeschwerde. Richtig.
Also es gibt von der AOPA Deutschland, AOPA steht für Association of Aircraft Owners and sorry, das ist die Aircraft Owners and Pilot Association. In Deutschland, die hat Verfassungsbeschwerde dagegen eingelegt. Es gibt noch unendlich viele andere Klagen in unterschiedlicher Rechtsausprägung, in der Regel bei den jeweiligen zuständigen Behörden, die diese Überprüfung durchführen müssen, die es das ja auch nicht immer ausgesucht haben, muss man dazu sagen. Ja und es ist durchaus möglich, dass der Paragraph 7, da das gleiche Schicksal erfährt wie der Paragraph 14 Absatz 3, der halt dieser rühmte Abschussparagraph war, aber bis jetzt ist das alles erstmal noch mal geltendes Recht.
Und das bedeutet auch, dass im Prinzip jetzt schon einmal komplett alle in Deutschland zugelassenen Piloten vollständig hinterfragt wurden und alle möglichen Zustimmungen von den Piloten selber, dass man einmal komplett über sie eine fette Akte anlegen kann, indem man einfach alle Geheimdienste und sonstigen Register, Datenbanken der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zusammenfasst. Sagen wir das richtig?
Korrekt, und zwar vom Motorseglerpilot, der irgendwie auf der grünen Wiese auf dem Mittelgebirge irgendwo mal, vor allem am Wochenende mal in die Luft steigt, bis zum Berufspiloten komplett.
Super, da fragt man sich natürlich jetzt, was eigentlich so gefährlich ist an den Piloten. Ich bin ja mit dir auch schon mal geflogen in so eine kleine Cessna mit zwei Sitzen. Wenn man da irgendwie losfliegt, dann kommt man sich vor wie bei Albatros Airlines, bei Bernhard und Bianca. Es rattert unter des Spots und das Ding macht irgendwie das Gefühl, dass wenn man so stark mit dem Ellenbogen gegen die Wand haut, dass man dann irgendwie schon draußen ist. Also alles andere als so eine Boeing, irgendwas, die auch mal dazu gebraucht werden kann, um irgendwelche Häuser zu beschädigen. Das Ding ist ja im Prinzip eine kleine Nuss-Schale. Wo sieht jetzt der Gesetzgeber die eigentliche Bedrohung?
Ja, das ist wohl eher eine psychologische, denn eine physikalische Sache. Also wenn man sich das mal so mit den Gesetzen der Physik, die ja gerüchteweise auch in Deutschland zutreffen, mal so alles ausrechnet, stellt man relativ schnell fest, dass gerade mit diesen angesprochenen kleinen Flugzeugen, es gibt ja noch kleinere, also das war ja jetzt immer schon ein ordentliches Eco-Klasse-Flugzeug, also mit Nutzlast ist da nicht so viel. Also wenn man damit Sprengstoff ins Ziel tragen will, also da ist mit jedem ordentlichen PKW wirklich mehr zu transportieren und von kleinen Bussen und LKWs reden wir da gar nicht mehr. Ja, also das ist, außerdem könnte man sich nicht auch fragen, wenn man sich mal die Statistik ansieht und stellt fest, also bis jetzt wurde noch kein einziger Terroranschlag weltweit mit einem Kleinflugzeug verübt. Aber wenn ich erst mal so sagen würde, naja, also Autobomben beispielsweise, da fallen mir jetzt direkt so auf Anhieb so ein paar Namen ein, also Oklaroma, Jakarta, Shamilchai, Bagdad, Kerbala und so weiter und so fort. Also da gibt es ja unendlich viele in Amm und jeder wird sich das selbst vergegenwärtigen können. Können Sie sich fragen, warum denn eigentlich unter diesen Vorzeichen nicht auch mal alle Autofahrer oder zumindest alle LKW-Fahrer mal überprüfen?
Alle Fußgänger, also ich denke so Sprengstoffgürtel werden ja meistens von Fußgängern benutzt und von daher müsste man eigentlich gegen die gefährlichen Fußgängerhorden vorgehen.
Ja, zumindest die U-Bahn-Fahrer. Also ich sage nur Tokio, Madrid.
Oh ja, oder die Theaterbesucher. Genau, also es ist wirklich hochgradig absurd und man fragt sich, warum da jetzt ausgerechnet die Piloten genommen werden. Ich finde es vor allem deshalb so verwundersam, weil ja nun eigentlich Fliegen ja nicht gerade so ein Hobby ist, was ganz billig ist. Also wenn man jetzt mal so vergleicht, ich miete mir ein Auto und ich miete mir ein Flugzeug, da muss man doch schon deutlich mehr Geld investieren in dieses Hobby. Oder liege ich damit auch falsch?
Na ja, also das hängt halt immer davon ab. Also wie überall im Leben auch. Man kann halt sehr teuer, man kann auch sehr günstig unterwegs sein. Also gerade mal diese kleine zweisätzige Maschine, da kommt man doch in sehr kurzer Zeit doch erstaunlich weit mit. Und wenn du das mal umrechnest in so eine typische Mietgebühr, da sind ja öfter auch Sprit mit enthalten und so weiter und so fort. Und dann bist du mit dem Auto, gerade wenn man die Maschine vollpackt, jetzt so in zwei oder vier Sitze, und das dann durch vier beziehungsweise zwei Personen teilt, ist das mit dem Flugzeug gar nicht so teuer, wie man denkt. Also das ist man meistens billiger als mit der Bahn sogar. Und das will ich euch mal was heißen.
Aber trotzdem ist es ja doch schon eine eher vermögendere Klientel, die sich jetzt dem Flugsport hingibt, gerade wenn man jetzt mal Motorsport ansieht. Habe ich so den Eindruck, dass sich da eigentlich der Staat mit einer gewissen Elite dieses Landes anlegt, die ja eigentlich, weiß ich nicht, solchen systematischen Überprüfungen gerade nicht besonders aufgeschlossen gegenüber stehen dürfte. Wie weiss man denn, erstmal muss man seine Unbedenklichkeit nachweisen und wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, gehört ja auch dazu, dass man seine Kontakte im Ausland belegt. Was war mit diesem Professor, der sich da öffentlich gewehrt hat?
Ja, das ist eine sehr lustige Geschichte. Jeder Professor hat einen offenen Brief an die für ihn zuständige Luftsicherheitsbehörde geschrieben. Das war in dem Fall das Regierungspräsidium Dresden. Er hat dann einfach mal das Ganze auf den Punkt gebracht und gesagt, ich bin ja nur ein anerkanter, internationaler Wissenschafter, das hat er so natürlich nicht gesagt, aber fragst du halt, mit welchen Ausländern darf ich denn in Zukunft überhaupt noch Kontakt haben, ja, ohne dass jetzt wirkliche Zweifel an meiner Zuverlässigkeit bestehen. Der schreibt dann so schöne Dinge wie, ich habe berufliche Kontakte zu US-amerikanischen Kollegen mit iranischem und pakistanischem Pass und wenn sie mir nicht schriftlich bestätigen, dass diese Kontakte für mich auch potenziell keine negativen Konsequenzen haben können, dann werde ich diese abbrechen, ich werde mich bei den Kollegen deshalb entschuldigen, ihnen die Gründe schriftlich mitteilen und sie über ihre Botschaften an die deutsche Regierung verweisen. Also auch eine durchaus adäquate Formulierung, das hat er dann sehr ausführlich getan. Und um nochmal auf die Anfangsfrage zurückzukommen, ist natürlich so, dass Piloten im Verhältnis zur Gesamtbevölkerung halt eine kleine überschaubare Gruppe darstellen, die deswegen auch hervorragend geeignet ist, um solche Sachen mal auszutesten, wie weit man denn gehen kann. Denn Piloten haben jetzt, also wenn ich das mit Autofahrern vergleiche, die haben halt nicht so eine Lobby wie der ADAC. Da gibt es halt so Vereinigungen wie die Aopa, die ich eben erwähnt habe, oder auch ein paar andere. Aber wie gesagt, es ist eine kleine Gruppe, die jetzt bei weitem nicht über die gleiche Medienpräsenz verfügt, wie das andere, soll ich es machen, Bevölkerungsgruppen oder Lobbyorganisationen haben oder in der Lage sind, durchzusetzen.
Das wiederum heißt natürlich... Ich kann mich nur an Franz Josef Strauß erinnern, der zu seinen Zeiten da irgendwie immer sehr massiv für die Freiheiten, der in der Fliege eingetreten ist, sei es nun die Flugbenzin-Besteuerung oder andere Sachen. Also gibt es da, also ist das jetzt wirklich so eine schwache Klientel, die sich nicht zu wehren weiß, wird dieses Gesetz auf jeden Fall sterben oder ist hier einfach erhöhte Wachsamkeit angebracht?
Na also die Klientel ist denke ich mal, also sind wir die Zielgruppe, wenn man so will, ist eigentlich eine sehr wachsame und auch eine sehr helle, muss man ja eigentlich sagen. Also da sind viele Leute bei, die das vielleicht nicht ganz so widerspruchslos hinnehmen, wenn da solche Dinge passieren, dann auf grund unklarer Kriterien solche Aussagen gemacht werden und die sich halt auch rechtlich zu wehren wissen. Also wie gesagt, neben dieser Verfassungsbeschwerde hängt da noch ein Ratten-Schwanz von Klageneinsprüchen und so weiter ist anhängig und wir werden sehen, wo das hinführt und ich denke, ich sehe schon ganz gute Chancen, dass es gekippt wird. Aber was man sich halt klar machen muss, das ist jetzt nichts, was nach dem Motto es betrifft ja nur andere, nicht mich, wo ich mich nicht mit beschäftigen muss. Denn, und da bin ich wirklich ganz fest der Überzeugung, wenn man das heute so durchgehen lässt, dann kommt garantiert morgen das nächste. Also wenn das Luftsicherheitsgesetz so, anscheinend keiner sagt was, alles geht gut, dann ist es sicherlich nur eine Frage der Zeit, dann kommt morgen das Sehsicherheitsgesetz und übermorgen das Straßenverkehrssicherheitsgesetz und so weiter und so fort. Mit den Mautdaten sind wir ja auch schon sehr weit jetzt und so weiter und so fort. Und deswegen heißt es wirklich auch als nicht unmittelbar Betroffener, dagegen vorzugehen, denn...
Ja, das ist ja eigentlich ganz klar, um einen absoluten Rechtsbruch von unten bis oben. Also erstmal, dass man selber seine eigenen Grundrechte aufgibt, halte ich schon mal für... Also das macht mich schon richtig fassungslos. Und dass man dann am Ende sozusagen noch nicht mal Rechtsmittel gegen irgendeinen Beschluss einlegen kann, dass man an irgendeiner Verkehrstätigkeit nicht teilnehmen kann, das ist ja genauso absurd an der Stelle.
Ja, und da ist halt auch wirklich die Frage, wenn man sich überlegt, dass da der Einzelne mit Nachrichtendienstlichen Mitteln von vorne bis hinten ausgeforscht wird, auf eigenen Antrag hin, ja, und also nebenbei bemerkt auch noch auf eigene Kosten, ja, als Privatplot hat man die Kosten dieser Überprüfung auch selber zu tragen. Es gibt zwar nach wie vor keine Gebührenordnung, aber...
Ach, das ist ja dann wie bei Brasil, wo auch irgendwie die populäre Forderung erhoben wird, dass die Leute für ihre Verhöre mehr bezahlen sollten. Da haben wir noch drüber gelacht und jetzt ist das tatsächlich so. Ja, also man muss es selber bezahlen, man muss selber sozusagen beantragen, dass man auf seine Grundrechte verzichtet und dann wird man nach Kriterien, die nicht existieren, von Leuten bewertet, wo nicht klar ist, wer das eigentlich sein soll. Das hatten wir noch gar nicht erwähnt. Das ist ja auch noch so eine Sache. Wer überprüft einen eigentlich? Also welche Behörde ist denn eigentlich tatsächlich zuständig?
Das hängt halt davon ab, wo man wohnt. Wir sind ja ein föderaler Staat. In dem Fall heißt das, dass je nach Erstwohnsitz eine unterschiedliche Landesbehörde dafür zuständig ist. Also die Luftsicherheitsbehörde, die im Gesetz erwähnt wird, die gibt es ja als solche nicht. Also es gibt jetzt keine Landesbehörde, wo irgendwo draußen ein Schild steht, hier ist die Luftsicherheitsbehörde, sondern es ist dann typischerweise das für den Wohnsitz zuständige Regierungspräsidium oder kann auch mal das Polizeipräsidium sein, in Hessen ist es, glaube ich, so je nachdem. Also es ist eigentlich eine einfache Landesbehörde und die entscheidet dann letztendlich darüber, auf Basis der gesicherten und gesammelten Materialien, ob die Zuverlässigkeit des Bewerbers vorliegt oder nicht.
Das heißt, dieser Person, also irgendeinem normalen Beamten bei irgendeinem Polizeipräsidium liegen dann sozusagen auch sämtliche Akten vor, die sie beim MAD eingeholt haben. Muss ich das so vorstellen?
So muss man sich das vorstellen, ja.
Das ist ja super. Hat der MAD da nicht auch was dagegen? Ja, diese Daten mal bereitzustellen.
Müssen wir ihn vielleicht mal fragen, ja. Also ich vermute auch, dass sich die Dienste das auch alles nicht so vorgestellt haben, aber also von der Gesetzeslage her, die gibt es auf jeden Fall her, ja.
Ja, das Luftsicherheitsgesetz. Eine weitere Absurdität, aber auf jeden Fall ein Gesetz, was den Eindruck macht, als ob man ganz massiv dagegen vorgehen sollte. Was würdest du vorschlagen? Welcher Protest ist hier angemessen? Naja, sich der Verfassungsbeschwerde anschließen?
Das ist immer eine Möglichkeit. Man kann auch mal der Opera beitreten und dann noch mit diesem Protokoll. Aber es gibt einfach viel, eigentlich viel direktere Dinge. Wir sind ja hier nach dem Vorhang der Demokratie. Man kann ja einfach mal den Abgeordneten seines Wahlkreises anschreiben und ihm sagen, also ich habe da gehört von diesem Luftsicherheitsgesetz, kann ja wohl nicht sein. Das ist, denke ich, immer noch die beste Methode. Wie gesagt, es gibt Möglichkeiten, sich da im Rahmen der Gruppe zu aktivieren. Das sollte man auf jeden Fall wahrnehmen. Aber auch als Einzelner ist es ja nicht so, dass man nicht seinen Mund auftun darf.
Da stehen ja jetzt auch gerade Wahlen an, so auf Landesebene in Berlin. Und was war noch gleich das andere Land, was wählt, war das Mecklenburg-Vorpommern. Und dort wäre es auf jeden Fall angemessen, mal nachzufragen, was die Parteien da zustehen. Überhaupt Einflussnahme auf solche politischen Ebene, also egal, ob eine Wahl ansteht oder nicht. Also man kann grundsätzlich immer mit seinen Abgeordneten reden und ihnen das Gefühl geben, dass man sich die Gesetze, die sie beschließen, vielleicht auch ab und zu mal durchliest und versucht zu verstehen.
Ja, das führt dann auch zu ganz lustigen Resultaten. Also beispielsweise, als dieser Abschlussparagraf im Verfassungsgericht verhandelt wurde, wurden ja auch die Initiatoren und treibende Kräfte hinter diesem Gesetz auch befragt. Und da kamen dann so Dinge ans Licht, wie ich erinnere mich noch, dass, ich glaube, Herr Schiel sagte, ja, also unter praktischen Gesichtspunkten würden diese Voraussetzungen ja praktisch niemals vorliegen. Und da musste ich dann doch die irritierte Rückfrage der Richter anhören, wenn das unter praktischen Gesichtspunkten denn noch niemals alles vorliegen würde, warum man denn dann eigentlich dann diesen Paragrafen gemacht hätte. Ja, ist ja durchaus eine, nicht von der Hand zu weise, eine Frage. Und...
Hatte er eine Antwort?
Na, keine richtige. Also ich hatte halt nur gesagt, naja, also praktisch...
Sie brauchen sich keine Sorgen machen über dieses Gesetz, es würde nie zur Anwendung kommen. Weil das, was wir daran beschreiben, ist so unrealistisch, das kann gar nicht passieren.
Ja, ich denke, das Gesetz hat vor allem da psychologische Komponente in der Entstehung gehabt. Also es gibt halt eine gewisse irrationale Angst, dass alles, was von oben kommt, halt unbeherrschbar und tendenziell gefährlich ist. Auch wenn es, wenn man sich das mal wieder aus anhand der Gesetze der Physik ausrechnet, nicht mehr, sondern eher weniger Gefahr darstellt, im Zweifelsfall als ein Auto oder gar ein Lkw. Aber diese irrationale Angst muss halt irgendwie bedient werden und dann muss man halt zu Aktionismus schreiten, auch wenn es, ja, wenn das dann Paragraphen hervorbringt, die eigentlich, nein, nein, nie ankommen.
In Berlin gab es ja ja auch so einen Fall, wo sich jemand umgebracht hat von dem Reichstag. Seitdem gibt es ja auch eine Ausnahmeregelung, richtig?
Seitdem gibt es eine Beschränkung des Luftraums über Berlin. Das heißt, man kann über, ja, dem Reichstag und der Umgebung, da darf man jetzt nicht mehr drüber fliegen, es sei denn, man ist lustigerweise halt ein Verkehrsflugzeug auf IFA-Anflug, also damit, worum man dann mal doch richtig Schaden anrichten könnte, das dann wieder auskommt. IFA-Verfahren, Instrumentenflugregeln.
Ach so, dann darf man sowieso überall lang fliegen?
Na ja, überall nicht, aber dann gelten diese Regeln nicht, weil man halt nach anderen Flugregeln unterwegs ist und den Linienverkehr möchte man jetzt, denke ich, auch aus nachvollziehbaren Gründen nicht verbieten, seine Anflugverfahren durchzuführen.
Aber im Prinzip kann das ja jeder umgehen. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt einfach in den Luftraum hineinfliegt, was soll man dann schon dagegen tun können?
Ja, das ist halt sowieso der Witz auch hinter dieser Zuverlässigkeitsüberprüfung. Also es gab ja auch im Rahmen dieser allgemeinen, wie soll ich sagen, Sensibilisierung in Sicherheitsfragen, gab es dann auch die Einführung von Flugbeschränkungsgebieten oberhalb von Atomkraftwerken. Da gibt es jetzt so einen kleinen Kreis auf der Karte um jedes Atomkraftwerk. Und da bitte nicht drüberfliegen, zumindest nicht tief genug. Also wenn ich das jetzt doch mache als Terrorist, und ich bin der Böse, und angenommen, ich könnte Schaden anrichten bei diesem Ding. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es mich dann wirklich davon abhält, dass ich jetzt neben beabsichtigtem Massenmord auch noch eine Verletzung des Luftraums da auf mich nehme. Also ob das dann der entscheidende Punkt ist, und in die paar Sekunden gibt es sowieso keine...
Das ist ungefähr so, als würde man so Schilder aufstellen. Terrorismus verboten.
Ja, so ungefähr. Und auch um nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, mit dieser Zuverlässigkeit überprüfen, das haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen. Das ist natürlich insofern auch doppelt bekannt, das betrifft ja natürlich nur deutsche Piloten. So, jetzt gibt es aber natürlich in Deutschland nicht nur deutsche Flugzeuge, ganz im Gegenteil.
Also nicht nur deutsche Piloten, sondern Piloten, also alle Leute, die in Deutschland einen Pilotenschein haben.
Das ist jetzt mal wieder was ganz anderes. Alle, die in Deutschland einen Pilotenschein haben, das können ja auch Ausländer sein, die einen ausländischen Pilotenschein haben. Oder jeder Deutsche kann auch, warum soll jeder keinen amerikanischen Pilotenschein haben?
Das ist auch alles möglich. Bezieht es sich jetzt nur auf deutsche Staatsangehörige oder bezieht es sich auf Leute, die in Deutschland einen Pilotenschein haben?
Na, das bezieht sich auf Leute mit einer deutschen Pilotenlizenz. Also, das heißt, wenn ich jetzt aus irgendeinem Grunde der Meinung wäre, dass mit der Zuflusskeitsprüfung OOO damals meine Gespräche da in Afghanistan könnten da vielleicht von Nachteil sein, dann besorge ich mir halt eine Lizenz in den USA oder in Österreich oder wo auch immer, muss ja gar nicht so weit reisen. Wunderbar, dann fliege ich halt mit einem N, also amerikanisch registrierten Flugzeug oder in Österreich oder was auch immer über Deutschland herum. Das kann mir auch keiner verbieten. Und ja, dann bin ich eigentlich noch viel unbeheiligter als die ganzen deutschen Piloten, die ja brav alle Zuverlässigkeit überprüft sind. Und insofern kamen sie natürlich schon Fragen. Na ja.
Und es ist ja auch so, dass wenn man jetzt aus dem Ausland kommt, darf man ja sowieso nach Deutschland reinfliegen, oder?
Das ist korrekt, ja.
Wie läuft das so normalerweise, wenn man jetzt so das Land wechselt? Ich flieg jetzt hier los und flieg jetzt Richtung Polen. Was passiert dann? Muss ich dann an der Grenze, muss ich dann in der Luft eine Kopie von meinem Pass durchfaxen?
Ja, noch einen Tankstopp einlegen und dann nochmal neben dem Zollflugzeug herfliegen und die Sachen drüber fliegen hier. Also eigentlich ist das, also hier in Europa ist das total trivial. Man sollte halt eine Stunde vor Abflug einen sogenannten Flugplan aufgeben. Da sagt man im Wesentlichen, ich fliege von A nach B, damit dann die Flugsichere im anderen Land auch weiß, wenn da ein neuer Punkt auf dem Radarschirm auftaucht. Okay, das ist das Flugzeug so und so, das kommt von da und da, das will nach da und dahin, alles prima. Das ist der sogenannte Flugplan. Das ist ein bewährtes und erprobtes Instrument, was es halt schon seit Jahrzehnten gibt. Und wie gesagt, eine Stunde vor Abflug sollte man das bei Auslandsflügen machen. Das ist es dann aber auch.
Und das war's. Also im Prinzip jeder, der einfach ankündigt, ich flieg jetzt hier nach München, der kann erstmal hinein in den Luftraum und dann ist er einfach da.
Korrekt, also man in anderen Staaten, die vielleicht nicht ganz so von den Gedanken der Freizügigkeit getragen sind, wie Nordkorea, ist das sicherlich ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber hier ist es erstmal so, wie gesagt, warum sollte man, warum auch nicht. Man kann ja auch mit seinem Auto problemlos von Salzburg nach München fahren, ohne dass man dazu vorher eine Genehmigung einholen muss.
Ich denke, wir haben jetzt hier die Problematik des Luftsicherheitsgesetzes hoffentlich ganz gut verdeutlicht. Hauptproblem, um es nochmal zu sagen, weil es macht einen irgendwie total fassungslos. Es gibt da halt ein Gesetz, es beschreibt Überprüfungsmaßnahmen, die eigentlich von sich aus, wenn der Staat sie selber in Angriff nehmen würde, komplett verboten sind, weil eben genau diese Datenerfassung, diese kombinierte Datenerfassung so nicht durchgeführt werden darf. Man wird gezwungen, die aber zu beantragen, sozusagen explizit seine Rechte auszuräumen, damit man eben seinen Pilotenschein behalten darf oder überhaupt erhalten darf. Und dafür muss man dann auch noch bezahlen. Und das Ganze findet nach Kriterien statt, die es nicht gibt. Von Leuten, die davon auch eigentlich keine Ahnung haben, weil sie irgendwie nur gerade mal so lokal zuständig sind.
Ja, so ist das wohl. Der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte hat auch vor kurzem noch gesagt, dass er doch sehen würde, dass Deutschland sich zwar nicht zum Überwachungsstaat, aber zumindest zur Überwachungsgesellschaft entwickeln würde. Und das ist sicherlich nicht falsch, eigentlich noch eher sehr zurückhaltend ausgedrückt. Und ich kann wirklich nur nochmal sagen, Holzauge sei wachsam, denn was heute nur Piloten und nebenbei bemerkt auch Bodenpersonal in Verkehrsflughafen betrifft, das kann morgen wirklich auch für jeden Auto- und U-Bahnfahrer prinzipiell Wirklichkeit werden. Und wenn halt Verhältnismäßigkeit, Recht und Augenmaß keinen Angang mehr in Gesetzgebungsverfahren finden, dann heißt das nicht nur für den Luftverkehr, sondern auch für alle Bereiche des gesellschaftlichen Zusammenlebens eigentlich eine Kapitulation vor einer Idee, die man eigentlich nicht in einer demokratischen Stadt haben möchte.
Ja, ich kann jetzt am Ende nur nochmal auf deinen Artikel verweisen. Der ist in der letzten Datenschleuder Nummer 90 erschienen. Die Datenschleuder könnt ihr, wenn ihr sie nicht abonniert habt, auch als PDF-Datei beziehen. Übrigens auch über Chaosradio. Es gibt für die Datenschleuder, für die PDF-Dateien einen eigenen Podcast-Feed. Und ihr könnt das natürlich auch direkt im Web herunterladen. Die Links da drauf, wie auch die Links auf viele andere Hinweise, die wir jetzt hier gegeben haben, findet ihr auf der zugehörigen Webseite zum Chaosradio Express 37 oder eben auch direkt in den Lyrics dieser MP3-Datei. Wenn ihr Fragen, Anregungen, Tipps oder Kritik für uns habt, immer gerne gesehen Chaosradio at ccc.de. Und worauf ich auch nochmal hinweisen möchte, das ist das neue Wiki, das wir eingerichtet haben, unter wiki.chaosradio.ccc.de. Dort sehen wir besonders gerne Themenvorschläge, aber auch Anmerkungen zu allen Sendungen, so auch dieser. Das heißt, dort kann man weiterführende Informationen, wenn man sich mit dem Thema auskennt oder vielleicht Fragen hat, noch mit unterbringen. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ihr bei dem Wiki noch kräftig mithält, damit das auch eine Ressource wird für alle. Ja, und das war's, Björn. Ich bedanke mich für das Gespräch über das Luftsicherheitsgesetz und mein Name, Tim Pritlove. Ich beschließe die 37. Ausgabe vom Chaosradio Express. Ich bin mir sicher, wir sehen uns bald wieder. Und ich sage Tschüss, Björn. Danke, bis bald und auf diesem Kanal geht es bald wieder weiter.